former NFL USC quarterback he's Mark
Sanchez
Showtime sports teamed up with former
NFL quarterback Mark Sanchez a new
digital series of in-depth engaging
conversations he had with a two Otunga
by Aloha
Justin Herbert and Jordan love it's
called intangibles presented by forth
and forever released this week on
Showtime sports youtube channel mark
also serves as a Superbowl correspondent
on inside the NFL on Showtime this past
season and Mark joins us now and whoa
look at that mustache what where'd you
whoa is that a quarantine mustache here
quarantine mustache my mom thinks I look
like Pancho Villa's you do if you if you
had one of those sombreros on or a 70s
quarterback you look like right yeah I
don't know it wasn't as bad as I thought
once my kid got into it I know they were
talking about playing the guitar but I
need my co-star with me I got a three
year old son yeah we yeah we heard that
you've been practicing guitar so I
thought that maybe we we roll this out
we got to do it we'll do it in the next
couple of weeks I'll work on the song
but he loves a
Old Town Road song and I'm literally
carrying him into like media day at
Super Bowl and he sees little nas ex
yeah and I didn't know no offense to him
I didn't know what he looked like
because I hadn't seen the music video I
just knew the song and my son's the one
three year old boy all right what do you
take let me start with Jordan love going
to the Packers because this wasn't a
value pic they went up to get him how
would you feel if you're Aaron Rodgers
the same way Favre probably felt it's
it's difficult but at the same time I
said this leading up to the draft that a
perfect place for either Herbert or
Jordan love was a place like New Orleans
or Green Bay where you have an
established starter so there shouldn't
be any question as in that organization
or outside that organization I know the
media will make it bigger than it needs
to be but Aaron Rodgers is the clear-cut
starter for as long as he wants to be
and until his play declines which I
don't see how
anytime soon I mean he still got another
five plus years if he rarely wants to
you know he's one of those Tom Brady
kind of guys who could do it for as long
as he wants but then why do it mark well
I think your your grooming your next guy
because you want to get they love Aaron
so much in my opinion
they want to get some of the best of
Aaron out of or injected into Jordan
Love and he needs to be around him
because Jordan love to be completely
Frank I don't think in my opinion that
he's ready to go into an NFL locker room
and go on that field and start day one
especially with an offseason like this
that just makes it even worse for
somebody like that because he can damage
his confidence and ruin him for the rest
of his career so brand size like that a
storied franchise where the quarterbacks
were pretty solid you got to give him a
chance to learn from someone like that
and Aaron benefited from that and it was
a an Instagram last night Favre was like
joking about it you know you saw that
yeah wait he wasn't joking fifteen years
ago this is it's gonna be weird on the
outside but I think Aaron will have
learned from that situation that he was
in and hopefully you know take him under
his wing or at least have the
professional courtesy to to help him out
from time to time I'm not saying yes to
just completely give up his job because
that's Aaron's job but this is the best
situation for Jordan love I really think
and somewhere like New Orleans would
have been great to where you have a guy
like I said who's an established starter
you don't have to worry about it
it's called intangibles presented by
forth and forever you sat down with to a
tongue of Eylau justin Herbert and
Jordan love you're talking about
intangibles and I bring this up when it
comes to trying to assess who's gonna be
able to make that next leap into the NFL
they all have talent everybody's got a
great highlight reel it's Tom Brady he
doesn't have you know the physical gifts
as much as he has the intangibles Drew
Brees the same way you can say Peyton
meant and like what is it that you're
looking for mark with these intangibles
with these young quarterbacks well I
think some of it is just mental
toughness what what have they been
through what what experience have they
had and had they bounce back from good
or bad also you know that's part of
their self-confidence just watching
their tape and speaking the language
with them what can can I try and walk
them down a road to correcting
themselves are they their own toughest
critic you know things like that keep
guys going for a long time I'm in this
league and keep you around for many
years but I think there's a little bit
of that in all three of these guys but
like you said they're all big enough
they're all strong enough they're all
fast enough
yeah sure some guys are a little bigger
a little stronger a little faster than
the others but they've all got something
now it just depends on where you land
and to be totally honest positioned
perfectly is somebody like Jordan love
cuz he's gonna reap the benefit just
like Patrick mahomes people are
comparing his his tape to patch them
homes for a reason
there's freaky arm Talent keep throw
some amazing balls but he also leaves
you scratching your head sometimes like
well what are you doing what what's that
why why there or why now and every
quarterbacks done that but when you
string a couple of those together on one
in one season like he had last year
granted he lost nine starters coaching
change offensive change offensive scheme
change that's fine but that was a lot of
interceptions for college at Utah State
so what did Patrick mo Holmes do his
last year at Texas Tech he threw a lot
of pics to a lot and so they get him
behind Alec Smith per year one of the
best at taking care of the football one
of the best at understanding how his
feet and progressions and everything is
a part of timing they all tie in
together how to get through your
progressions with Andy Reid who's now
been validated as a great coordinator
even though we've known that forever
then what happens now you cut him loose
after a year of just figuring things out
just examining taking in information
like it's fun just soak it all in and
that's what you can potentially have and
if Jordan Love has any sense to him
which I think he does after spin down
with him he's just gonna be without
being you know an annoying little
brother he's got to be Aaron Rodgers
little brother and just watch him how
does he watch t why are you looking at
that ask questions without you know the
guy figure out what are you doing right
what he's doing wrong and just make
makin he can't buy enough notebooks and
pencils right now
first investment if I just learn from
the guy cuz he's one of the best of all
time but if I look at this Jordan loves
not gonna play this year I hope to it
doesn't play this year well Joe burro is
gonna play but then that brings me to
Justin Herbert and I don't think he's
ready to play right now either you got
Tyrod Taylor but I wonder how quickly
you know in the old days if you're
drafted this high as you know I mean
you're going in and now you play and you
know as Brady told me years ago if I had
played right away I'd be out of the
league I needed to understand how to
slow the game down all of those things
if you're the Chargers what do you do
with Justin Herbert here's the problem
and I don't think Chargers fans are
gonna love this they got a new stadium
it's a big media market they're
competing with the Rams constantly the
Rams just went to the Superbowl two
years ago so they need to sell jerseys
sell tickets there's this other factor
this other force right this driving
force of you know a monetary force right
and they're gonna push there's gonna be
pressure to play this kid if Tyrod
Taylor goes three and out a couple times
in a row I guarantee it just because he
was drafted so high just because when
you see him in training camp I guarantee
there's gonna be highlights all over the
the news channels talking about wow did
you see that ball and look at how great
his feet are and he's so big and I mean
you look at him you fall in love with
the kid it's unbelievable his physical
attributes he's six six and ran a sub
for seven it's freaky now no there's
gonna be pressure to play him my only
advice to Anthony Lynn who was our
running backs coach in in New York with
the Jets just give him some time man let
him marinate
let him sit in the oven take him out
when he's ready and not a minute too
soon or else you might spoil it
how many times did and you're playing
against Brady twice a year in the AFC
East did you ever look over and watch
him on the field and go how the hell is
he doing this so during the time he was
still building some of that he obviously
had that aura around him and you know
there's like a man as a competitor
you're like you want to you want to beat
his ass you know you're not like I'm not
in this to you know oh just wow it's
somebody I wanted okay if this guy's ass
knowing what he's done and seeing him
come back in games like I'm telling you
I don't know if I had any nails left
after that after the divisional game in
Foxborough because they're starting to
mount a comeback like we hit him hard
early got him down early and it's 28 14
but I mean we're talking with three
minutes left that thing can flip quick
they could score 17 points fast so you
just have so much respect for the guy
that in some ways you're terrified in
other ways you just want to go beat it
you know it's but there's nothing but
marquee you're not watching mahomes play
quarterback you're not watching Aaron
Rodgers play quarterback you're not
watching Lamar key like I'm looking at a
guy who looks like a normal guy playing
quarterback physically looks normal but
he's abnormal why it's between his ears
man he's he's figured it out he's
supremely confident and he a lot like
the military these guys get in these
very difficult situations but they know
exactly what to do they have a process
they have a checklist and he can do it
stow quickly and he has this mental
rolodex of you know coverages and
blitzes and pressures that he'd seen
before and he can immediately pull it up
without having to go through you know
like certain people you got it okay was
that two weeks ago two years ago AFC
Championship game was that no no I
guarantee you right away hey you know
2014 versus the Broncos and playoffs on
the road but I guarantee he knows that
and that's what's made him so good he
also you can tell when you've been in
the same system for a long time Dan when
you have five options you're not
necessarily going through all five
options it's almost the guys who can
process the quickest or the ones who
know okay I'm definitely not going to
him I'm not going to him either now I'm
down to three and if there's any
pressure I have a contingency plan I
know exactly where to go if this thing
if everything goes to crap I know
exactly where to go and that's that's
been his thing and then even when
there's nowhere to go he falls down and
that is one of the hardest things to do
I'm telling you he'll you're right
somebody a gift he'll give somebody a
gift in the eighth row and just sail
Stadium but he doesn't care because he
knows there's a there's a bigger goal in
mind I don't need that one play to beat
you but that one play could lose the
game for us well that's what Nick Saban
brought up because I said what concerns
you and he said because he knew too and
never gives up on a play and I said yeah
like you if Tom and Peyton didn't have
anything there they would just fall in
the Peter fetal position you know
Russell Wilson is in between he'll
extend a play but he'll get out of like
he's smart if I was one of these
athletic quarterbacks mobile
quarterbacks I just say study Russell
Wilson because right he picks his spots
when to run when to slide when to get
out of bounds Brady is just hey nothing
there I'm going down that's it exactly
and I guarantee you a lot of that for
Russell Wilson where he's learned that
and even his demeanor on the field like
constantly positive that's so P Carroll
and after being around Pete for so long
he reminds you every single meeting when
you start the year in training camp he
holds a football and he says it's all
about this he says when you hold this
you hold the hopes and dreams and
aspirations of the entire franchise
everything from the guy cooking the food
in the cafeteria to the guy washing your
dirty job this is the most important
thing in our entire universe is that
clear it's all about the ball that's it
so he knows hey man I can't take hits
and lose the football I can't give the
ball to the other team and that's one of
the hardest things to do is to give up
to say uncle on the field when you're so
competitive I mean it's it's easier to
try and make and I told Jordan love this
I said don't make me chicken salad out
of chicken crap I can't do that if it's
over it's over sale it and it's hard
that's great advice
it's called intangibles presented by
forth and forever
and it's a release this week on Showtime
Sports YouTube channel Mark Sanchez
poncho via the former NFL USC
quarterback do you joke at all with Pete
Carroll about when you were coming out
he didn't want you to come out he said
he would have like he was gonna throw
himself in front of the door that he
wouldn't let you out of USC to go pro
dude can you joke about that now
we actually talked about it a little bit
but so you know the night before I don't
know if I
I don't know if I said it on this show
or somewhere but the night before he was
in my apartment at school and we had
in-n-out burger at like till like 2:00
in the morning and we were just talking
talking about life talking about
football talking about our families and
everything you know and he's like
literally like when he leaves he just
kind of like hey listen I'm not gonna
agree with you tomorrow but you know I
want you to do well like I supported you
I just I don't agree with what you're
doing I would say that to my kid you
know if he was you or whatever and so I
understood well it just came across so
poorly and then there's like the picture
in the LA Times where he's like walking
off and I'm kind of like and then so it
just looks over the optics of it looks
so bad yeah they didn't remember we left
school everything had ended I kind of
felt like a weird vibe in the room in
the press conference and then it just
blew up and you know this is 2009 so
Twitter's starting to take off and I
mean it just like it exploded and I
remember him calling me and he goes
golly what the heck is going on Mikey
were don't support you like I said coach
don't even worry about I'm looking at
the picture it looks like you don't know
each other and if you don't hate each
other
it looks like 2020 passing something
it's weird
great great appearance great to have you
on mark thank you very much and good
luck with Showtime Sports appreciate it
guys we'll talk to you soon all right
that's Mark Sanchez there's good stuff